andrew is with us on line four hi Andrew
and Massachusetts how are you hey Dave
I'm good are you better than I deserve
what's up um this one say thanks for
taking my call first of all should I
appreciate that
sure no I have a question hello hello hi
I've got a school question for you okay
so I did a two-year program at a
community college cash flow cash flow in
my first year there and I got a loan for
my second year and a transfer I
graduated in business and I transferred
over to state school so I did I did one
semester there and during this time my
my dad took over a business that he's
been working out for 30 years automobile
business and I'm working there and I got
my appraisers licensed in the state of
Massachusetts so I'm working as the
damage appraiser and I'm just wondering
I'm thinking about staying with this
company and eventually taking it over
I've talked to my dad and he's probably
gonna work for another 10 to 12 years
and sell it over to me mm-hmm and I'm
just wondering if I should continue
going to school or not mm-hmm okay
well the actual completion of the degree
won't matter but what does matter is the
knowledge base okay if you're gonna run
a business and you've had more classes
on accounting more classes on marketing
more classes on statistical analysis
more classes with standard business
classes on Finance and so on the better
decisions you're gonna make you better
tools and your belt to do your job
running the business later today I would
not worry about it today you're not in a
panic I would take the income that
you've got you've got a good career
started there let's go make some money
let's get these debts paid off that you
do have and then if you want to save up
and do some work in the evenings and try
to complete your degree and in
process put some of those tools in your
belt that you maybe don't have today
it'll be helpful to you but there's
plenty of people run very successful
businesses with less education than
you've currently got right you also but
the other part of this is you want to
commit if you're in in anything but
particularly in business and it's true
in medicine and law other things you
want to commit to being a lifelong
learner a reader you need to read
business books really dersh it bucks and
um you know ah books on entrepreneurship
and you need to constantly be reading
and growing and college doesn't doesn't
you know when you got school if you stop
learning then in just a few years you're
irrelevant so you have that you have to
keep reading and growing and learning
all the time you have to keep adding to
your knowledge base as you go if you
keep doing that you'll be fine and then
if you wanted to go back and you know
finish up your finish up your bachelor's
you're probably not that far out from
finishing it that's a fine thing to do
and you know some of the classwork that
you do to get that would be valuable to
you and running the business I have a
four year degrees all I have I'm not got
a masters and but I'm a lifelong learner
in addition to that and so I probably
got several PhDs in terms of the amount
of information I have ingested in the 35
40 years I've been doing business and so
that's what you're looking at you're
trying to learn trying to grow and
trying to add to it but the you know my
basic four year degree is fair was very
helpful for that matter still very
helpful a lot of those basic things
basic accounting understanding and gap
principles and you know Finance
principles are things I use on the air
here every day my job is to not make
them sound like gobbledygook instead put
the cookies on a shelf where everybody
can reach them but I'm using the
concepts and the critical thinking
skills that you know that we were taught
in our academic education so education
is valuable is it mandatory where you
slap your fist on the table say you're
not gonna be successful as you go back
right now no no I think you're gonna
make some money and get your you know
get get a little nest egg put back get
yourself out of debt
emergency fund in place if you want to
save up and pay for class work and do
some evening work as you go you're gonna
be fine and learn the business from your
dad learn the business from other people
in the business learn best practices get
involved in stuff like on trade
leadership some of the other things that
people have out there where you're
growing and learning is a leader and
those things you'll be just fine you'll
be just fine
lots of people with high school
education or even less have been very
successful in business there's a lot
more to it than simply getting a degree